♪ ♪
LAWRENCE: TWOK CROSS COUNTRY WE
BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT AS
AMERICAN NAMES A NEW MURDER
CAPITAL CRIME AND MURDERS ARE
SURGING IN NEW ORLEANS.
AND ELECTED OFFICIALS SEEM TO
CARE MORE ABOUT CRIMINALS THAN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITY.
THEIR STWENGT CONTINUE TO BEG
FOR HELP AND THOSE IN CHARGE ARE
NOT LISTENING OVER THE LAST YEAR
MURDERS HAVE INCREASED BY 34%.
ARM ROBBERIES HAVE SKYROCKETED
BY NEARLY 50% WHILE CARJACKINGS,
THEFT AND GUN RELATED VIOLENT
CONTINUE TO CLIMB AS WELL.
AND AMERICAN CITY THAT WAS ONCE
A YULE IS NOW IN TOTAL DECAY AND
I WENT DOWN TO NEW ORLEANS TO
SEE THE SITUATION FOR MYSELF.
AND SPOKE TO MOTHER WHO JUST
LOST HER SON TWO WEEKS AGO TO
GUN VIOLENCE.
WATCH.
>> I STILL THINK IT'S A DREAM.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I'M COPING WITH
IT.
BECAUSE --
I'M NOT CRYING --
IT JUST HURT ALL OVER MY BODY.
JUST HURTING --
IT IS NOT A CRIME.
IT IS A HURTING --
DON'T HAVE NO AIR.
IT'S LIKE YOUR BODY JUST SHUTS
DOWN.
NOBODY DON'T WANT TO BECAUSE I'M
THE NOT CRYING.
I'M HURTING I'M WAITING ON MY
SON TO CALL ME AND GO BY HIS
HOUSE AND IT IS UNBELIEVABLE
THAT HE'S WITH THE REASON HE'S
DEAD --
FROM IT DON'T MAKE NO SENSE --
OUT HERE WITH NOBODY.
THEIR PARENTS, DAD NOT IN THEIR
LIVES IT IS JUST OUT HERE.
LAWRENCE: TAKE ME BACK TO THE
DAY WHERE YOU GOT THE NEWS TWO
WEEKS AGO THAT YOU LOST YOUR
SON.
>> I SEE WHERE I CAN GET INTO
THE AMBULANCE --
NO YOU GET INTO THE VEHICLE --
BECAUSE OF CORONA I RAN BACK TO
THE CAR FOLLOWED DOWN --
AND I GOT THERE --
FIVE MINUTES LATER, CALL ME TOLD
ME MY CHILD WAS DEAD.
LAWRENCE: THERE WAS ONCE A POINT
IN HISTORY WHERE YOU DID
SOMETHING, YOU PAY FOR YOUR
CRIME.
AND THAT GAVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE YOUR LIFE
AROUND.
AND GO BACK IN SOCIETY AND YOU
DIDN'T WANT TO GO BACK TO THAT
PLACE.
BUT RIGHT NOW SEEMS LIKE --
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AREN'T PAYING
FOR WHAT THEY DO.
LES THEY DON'T VALUE LIFE.
>> THEIR SITUATION THERE WHICH
YOU JUST SAY IS LEAK, IF THEY DO
PAY FOR IT WHAT THEY LEARNING
AND THE JUSTICE, CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
ING RIGHT NOW, I DID IS 12 YEARS
THEY DON'T HAVE NOTHING FOR US
TO DO AND NOTHING TO OFFER US.
FIRST OF ALL, SCHOOLING IS A
GAME.
REENTRY PARENTS SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ALL PROGRAMMERS ARE GAME.
A PERSON LIKE ME COMING HOME
FROM DOING 12 YEARS GOT TO GO
LEARN NOTHING IN THERE SO IT'S
NO WINNING THEY GO TO JAIL WHAT
GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY GOING TO DIE IN THERE
BECAUSE NOBODY COULD HELP THEM.
PEOPLE GETTING THEM IN AND STAFF
UP ALL DAY EVERY DAY.
IF I LOSE MY CHILD TO THE SYSTEM
THEY'RE GONG DIE BECAUSE
CRIMINAL SYSTEM IS MESSED UP.
♪ ♪
LAWRENCE: YOUR CITY IS THE
MURDER CAPITOL OF THE COUNTRY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> THAT'S A SLAP --
WHOLE CITY FACE A BLACK EYE
PICTURE IN THE WHOLE CITY FACE.
IT IS A CRISES, IT'S A DISASTER.
>> HOW MANY FUNERALS HAVE YOU
GONE TO THIS YEAR?
>> TOTAL OF 66 NOW.
LAST FRIDAY THE YOUNG MAN WAS 31
YEARS OLD.
HE WAS THE OLDEST --
THE OTHER 65 OF THEM THE KIDS
WERE 17 ON DOWN.
>> WHEN YOU GO TO THESE FUNERALS
AND YOU GRIEVE WITH THESE
FAMILIES, AND THEY'RE ASKING FOR
JUSTICE FOR THEIR KIDS, ARE ANY
OF THE CITY COUNCIL ELECTED
OFFICIALS THERE AT THESE
FUNERALS?
NO.
>> SOME OF THEM HAVE COME TO A
FUNERAL WHEN IT IS SOMEBODY
CLOSE TO THEM.
BUT AS EVERYBODY ELSE THERM AT
THE LAST WEEK FUNERAL IT WAS AT
A LOT OF FUNERALS.
YOU KNOW.
SO --
MY PERSONAL OPINION IS THAT IN
THE WAY I FEEL IF THEY HAVE A
PLAN AND IF THEY WAS GOING TO DO
SOMETHING SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN
DOING IT AND DONE BY NOW.
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TAKEN --
>> THERE'S NO PLAN.
THEY ACT LIKE THEY HAVE ONE.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT GOVERNMENT
IS THERE FOR.
>> POLICE OFFICERS ARE LEAVING
FORCE TOO.
I HAVE A --
I MEAN WE HAVE A RECORD SHORTAGE
RIGHT NOW WITH OFFICERS AS WELL.
DGES WELL, WHEN YOU --
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH NO
RESPECT FROM CITIZENS AND
SOMEBODY GAVE THEM THE GREEN
LIGHT THAT HEY CRIMINAL SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW, JUSTICE SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING HAND IN HAND.
SO YOU MIGHT --
MIGHT BEAT THIS CHARGE SO WHEN
YOU THINK YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH
SOMETHING THEY'RE GOING TO DO
IT.
>> HAVE WE FAILED OUR CHILDREN
IN NEW ORLEANS?
>> POINT BLANK, I DROPPED A
POINT TOO AS A FATHER, AS A
PERSON THAT COME FROM A POVERTY
COMMUNITY, I COULD HAVE DONE
MORE.
YOU KNOW, I'VE DONE SOME THINGS
I DID PROGRAMS.
BUT THERE WAS NOT CONSISTENT,
YOU KNOW, AND I DON'T TO BLAME
WHY IT WASN'T KING THE IT WAS
JUST THAT WHEN EVERY
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGE POSITIONS,
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE PROGRAMS IN
PLACE, THOSE PROGRAMS WENT OUT
WINDOW BECAUSE NEW PEOPLE CAME
INTO THE ADMINISTRATION.
LAWREN